the conference on the future of europe's
in full swing
this weekend the plenary convened in
strasbourg with citizens at the center
of the process the success of this
conference
depends from the capacity we have to
implement the conclusions of the
conference
representatives from the european youth
event and from citizens panels shared
their ideas with institutions
i'm just like a normal european young
citizen and now i'm sitting at one table
with a politician
[Music]
for the first time in european history
we put together
european parliamentarians national
parliamentarians national governments
commissioners and representatives of the
citizens
the proposals my group came up with were
about education to
give
the opportunity
to schools to talk more about like
intercultural skills
[Music]
the european democracy needs to be more
transparent there need to be more ways
for people to participate in the eu
citizens naturally because the citizens
will be actively participating in this
in these debates for for the first time
my generation is pretty engaged to
change europe and to bring europe
forward to find a way to
create a better world
we will have plenty sessions where the
citizens come to tell
to the other participants
what they want what their
recommendations are
[Music]
you